Oprah produce when they see us and and
and I know that you have had some real
quality time with Oprah and everyone
wants to know what that's like you know
did you go on vacation with her yeah I
mean heaven on earth she's just an
amazing individual she really is
okay everyone says that and I accept it
and I think okay great specifics about
the vacation where did you go
what was it light first of all when did
you find out that you were gonna get to
go on a vacation with go find a
non-disclosure yeah I don't take those
things seriously you get sued not me we
went to Maui it was I mean we'll see I
was originally traveling with Ava
Duvernay who direct it when they see us
and we were going to the Bahamas and
then she called me after I was already
packed and said hey you know Oprah X if
we would like to come to Maui she said
think about it and call me back
[Laughter]
did you pack a lot of whole clothes when
you go on vacation you know how it is
you wear things on vacation you would
never wear at home you know I didn't
know if Gayle of step knit was gonna be
there I needed to be on my best behavior
sure so you quickly you quickly got some
good clothes proper yeah attire and so
you go and you stay with Oprah there is
one picture of you guys it's you and
Oprah in a golf cart I think I think
you're in a golf cart Bucky now it's a
buggy
it's a buggy it's a bad thing you see me
buckling up cuz I said hey lady do you
know how to drive this thing and that
woman has a lead foot I'm gonna go ahead
and tell it we took off so fast I was
like Oh Lord my wig is gonna fly off
you know you know people say jesus take
the wheel I said Oprah got the whale
yeah I'm going to die yeah how because I
felt like my life flashed in front of my
face you driving so fast I said I will
forever be linked to Oakland
[Laughter]
[Applause]